yes hello good morning to you on the
west coast here it's good evening from
the Pharaohs
my name is voyeurism I'm a political
scientist so I'm not geneticist or
biologist or statisticians but I work
with the fara Genome Project far gen
that I will take you through this
journey our thoughts on what we are
working with so we call this we call
this an a holistic genomic health
approach because this is going a bit
broader than than just then sequencing
itself it goes a lot into what we want
to use it for first picture overview of
the Pharos these are small islands in
the North Atlantic they are of a rough
hard nature and very steep mountains so
this is more to give you an idea on how
life has been in ancient times for the
last house in the years before we got
modernity in the furrows so you get an
impression of our small society in that
way our proposal is to implement routine
whole genome sequencing in healthcare
and our society the Faroe Islands as
50,000 people is very small but we also
want to have this cornerstone for
individualized health care and on the
future work on the prevention part the
treatment cost effectiveness and the
implementation part and it's also a way
to to provide this national
international research foundation we
believe there is a great value in the
research we can do in the furrows which
I will come in to explain later on and
we believe we will work with the genomic
healthcare model that's of course based
in our national model but also has a
global component
Comfort ility so we can work with so
what we are doing first is a pilot study
to explore this critical scientific
technical ethical legal and social
aspects and then of course we need to
create this infrastructure for long-term
management and maintenance and evolution
of the system this is another picture
view of the Pharos if you if you can
look at these two small villages in
until 50 60 70 years ago you wouldn't
have a road in between villages and
every village would be a micro society
in itself so that's just in order to
give you an idea on on on even that you
have a micro society in the furrows you
would still have a lot of micro
societies inside the Pharos because
every village was its own society in its
way so where are the Pharaohs you can
see them here in between Iceland Norway
and Scotland I think they're drawn a
fair amount bigger than they are in
reality on this picture but this is in
the middle of the North Atlantic's so we
are far away from from closest neighbors
and we live in a rough high nor to see
so what is far John in brief a genome
sequence of every fairways who wants to
to store the data electronically in our
electronic health records or in our
system if if there is to be done
research in it we will follow the
current procedures with permissions from
ethical ethical scientific committee
data thoradine
and the form consent and and we also
need to have an agreement with our
genetic biobank in order to do that in
the health system the doctor requires a
specific information from the genome
which is looked at but then it has to be
required with with a necessarly cat in
medical form we have a prototype Chris
proposed workflow
where we held the blood sample we have
the whole genome sequence then we have
stored it so it can be linked to the
other data which I will explain later on
that we have in our system and if you as
and which will come into the into the
medical system the clinical responsible
for this biobank can can open the or can
my request give some data and you can do
the run on the genome to have this
question run it's it's a bit it's fairly
equal that you would do with on with a
blood test today and then we have them
we have the follow up with the teams on
those parts so it's not so different
from from as we see medical practice
today as I said before the research and
the research part we we need each
research project needs approval and the
genetic biobank has the authority to
identify disease groups in our darkness
the honesty in registering and even if
you if you give an informed consent to
be part of the far gen to give you
genome to the version you you still have
to be recon scented for a specific
research project and we have a big
discussion on the incidental findings as
we do and in the rest of the world and
there is a high focus on the right not
to know but also to to the
recommendation of the of the ACE ACMG
report that came earlier this year I
think and here you can see two of the
lead authors and me outside the Eagle
the pop words were the secret of life
were Watson and Crick made their
presentation on the DNA structure so
this was a celebration conference in
April I think in Cambridge so where is
our motivation it's a better health care
we live in a very small society which is
far
away from everything so for us it's
really a struggle brain-drain is a
challenge all the time so it's it's
really a struggle to keep up with the
standards that we can see in our
neighboring countries so when we do we
do really need to fight also to survive
at the same level as our neighboring
countries are doing so better healthcare
is one of the parameters that people are
looking for or the quality of health
care but we also think that we can
participate in solving a global
challenge to make genetic and genomic
information usable in the clinical
settings and also to do research parts
of it in the settings because we believe
we have a very good system for this
normally we would see isolation and and
smallness as as negative things that we
are far away and very isolated and the
country is pretty small but in this case
it's it's a benefit and it's also a
society where we can see on polls that
there's a high trust and also
transparency in the system we have equal
to the Nordic countries we have a lot of
data we have a lot of health data which
is good for for a project of this kind
and then of course we have a one
specific case with CDD the carnitine
transporter deficiency which has caused
a lot of attention the last years where
fairly young people could drop that but
it's it's a genetic disease that's easy
treatable with some Connaughton
supplement shows which which we work a
lot with and that has taken a lot of
attention to the population on knowing
more about about your genetic genetics
in the people and there is clearly a
political wish to develop research
competences and to keep knowledge in the
furrows and to evolve the knowledge and
develop the knowledge in the furrows to
have a biotechnology cluster and job
creation as a part of this project
and to see if this also can be a part of
initiating by own health business we
already have a lot of bio knowledge as
fishery and aquaculture is our main
income and our for instance our Solomon
breeding is supposed to be the best in
the world so we have some really good
qualities on on this area this is not
we're not just starting on without
anything the picture you can see is is
the governmental office of the Prime
Minister and just in front of that is
supposed to be the oldest site
parliamentary sites in the world which
the old half think I think met in
ancient times one of the things that
it's also a part of a pressure this is
being first with using these genomic
things so going back a bit of the
history the picture here you can see the
main hospital on the Pharaohs in Thor
founding the Pharaohs so in the Asian
decode in ninety eight came to the
Pharaohs
with an approach to have a cooperation
to join forces to work with both the
Icelandic and Faroese population but for
several reasons that that didn't really
realized anything but it caused a huge
debate in the Pharaohs and ethical
debate on on the use and if genomics and
genetics should be used in the Pharaohs
and and that discussion was very hard
very rough and lasted for yes six seven
eight years and away from 98 to almost
2006 or some part of it but suddenly and
in 2005 a little bit before the began my
work with with a political wish to have
a bio back act to actually have a low
frame on the biomech and in 2005 it was
passed and then the parliament with as
far as I remember full agreement and it
it paved the path to to have a genetic
bio bank started and this bio Bank
started
in 2006 in 2007 we had the first
research project inside these frames
inside the biobank and and inside the
biobank 'acts frames starting slowly and
2008 we started slowly with a
feasibility study of larger genomic
projects in the furrows and from 2009 it
became the fajr an idea and the concept
of the initiation of of this project
today it's a part of the Department of
research and development and the
Ministry of Health which I work for so
we can go back to the bio Bank Act we
have used this purpose of the act as our
our guidelines to work with it says on
the first paragraph that the point is
that we have to protect the right of
individuals and concern with human
genetic research to establish the
parameters for and encourage research in
the Faroe Islands into human genetics
and the such research my in the end
advance competences and cure in the
prevention of disease advanced
competencies within the various national
healthcare system and to establish a
consummate research environment in the
Faroe Islands so these are very good
points guidelines to help which we have
worked up with the political will in
this part so it's clearly also to
develop the Faroes health care system
and in this part so in the in the ferry
system we have a geology register we
have some phenotypic information we have
tissue register we have Pharma
information some part information the
organiz registry and genotype we have
health science project and we are now
working with having the genomes in and
this is the research part of this is
everything everything is is very much
organized by them by the genetic bio
bank so we have a good
we have a good framework in in this we
believe so what we think in this part is
that we have an infrastructure which
will be hosted by the genetic bio bank
where we can have information going both
to the health to the clinical part and
into the research part so so this is
both to develop knowledge for direct
clinical use and to have a bio improve a
biobank with genomic research or with
genomic information so we can have a
research part in it and this is just a
simple simple overview of ancestors if
you take 10 generations which is
probably in generally 300 years you
would have a thousand and 24 ancestors
in that part if we then look at the
Faroes population there was a fairly
stable population on between three to
three four thousand until until the 1750
1800s so you can see that there is a
there has been not been many people
around so there is a lot of of orders
are very close familiarity in the ferry
system in that way
and so to the implementation part the
picture here of is of the various prime
minister who also thinks very highly of
this project but we need to have the
public health system
I should explain that the ferry system
is the whole system is it's one public
health system it's a very small society
very small country fifty thousand people
so we have one public health system
there are some few private actors on the
islands in some areas of health care but
in general this is one public health
system everything is inside one frame
and it's all digitalized today with
digitalize information and so we have
the genetic bio bank inside this part
where we have to have the generator we
have the hospital system that has to be
prepared and made ready to do the
usability of the data excuse me I just
need to close a door sorry I'm back
first time I've been closing a door
during the presentation then we have the
digital health care system which we call
the ths and Faroese where he aged our
system and we have the ethical legal and
social societal implication that we have
to work with the Elsi requirements that
we have to take care of as well I should
say in that concern that by official
international statistics the Pharos has
has the lowest crime rate in the world
and it's the most equal equal society in
the Agena index so so so so we we don't
have this issue of we don't have a race
issue in this form we don't have then
issue of different classes and access to
health care and
helped things so that's a benefit when
you work with with unequal access to to
some new benefits in the healthcare the
political system has been sponsoring
this project for since it started so
they know about it and of course there
are questions about how how it should go
and have a stand and other things but
but this has been inside the political
frame since it started and now a big
part of this is also to get the
administrative system to take the
different accounts on on on different
areas it's not all inside a health
health ministry is also different
ministry that has ten and different
agencies that that have to be integrated
into the system and and we have paid a
lot of attention to education we have
worked with having genetic genomics as a
part of the curriculum in the school
from first grade through high school and
taking it from a bit of a different
approach with with having a case or four
cases that we that we work with making
putting more and more more and more
challenges to us as you go higher into
the system and instead of making one
subject of genomics or genetics we we
make cases applicable to mathematics to
Chancery to biology to history to also
to religion or society and we have we
have we are not finished with developing
that part but we hope that that's
something we can roll out pretty soon
and I've also been in in connection with
our with our Ministry of Education in
order to to educate the teachers in
using this material and there's a need
for a buy-in from healthcare and is as
in every health care systems around the
world people most people concede
the potential and genetics and genomics
but also that it needs some changes and
that's something to work with to have
the buy-in from the healthcare even if
we believe we have we have a reasonably
good buy-in from that part and we are
also working a lot with buy-in from the
people and that's an ongoing process
that's and I don't know if that ever
stops but it's it's about information
and and having contact with people and
explaining the possibilities and and
also the concerns with genomics we have
a good cooperation also with our digital
healthcare system and and this is this
is very important because the future we
we see is not just the genomics is
everything is very much a translational
approach where we can put where we can
have genomics as the baseline but have
many different relevant health
information attached to this this also
means that that the Western healthcare
system are trying to find some solutions
to that the healthcare is becoming too
expensive and one part of that is to
give back some some of some of the
knowledge back to to the persons
themself so so people also would not be
so much in the hospital but having
treatment at home with information and
the genomic is playing a big part in
that
so in this way we won't have all day
time in one system so the pilot is to
implement a prototype workflow to have
this monitoring of the scientific
technical ethical and societal impacts
or implications to work with the
education and public awareness to reach
out to people and that way to have a
fair ways referenced you know
and there are some options to go for
some rare Mendelian conditions cancers
to specific various diseases this has
also been a major concern because we
have some specific various concerns I
mentioned the CDD and these are things
that we need to work with ourselves in
our society because they are they are a
concern in our society not a big concern
in most other societies and we also
really really emphasize to have a focus
on that this is a health project this is
not about concerning people with disease
this is a lot about health and we have a
very healthy population when us numbers
show that we are very high in the top on
the expected living age so so we also
want to have a focus on looking at why
the Faroes are are so so healthy and we
hope that we in
2013 but we go into 2000 the mid of 2014
to have a thousand sequenced individuals
in this part and and also to see if we
can work with that public health tool
where we can have some general
information that are used that is usable
for for them for the public health
knowledge in and a tool in that way and
to work with the outreach which is both
the public awareness but very much also
education in that way and of course one
of the things that we we need to look at
is is that we don't always know which
genetic origin is behind the phenotypic
look look as you see in in this picture
and then I have this funny story that
that my wife is is from Peru and this
is very much in the Native American
Indian ink Indian from Peru from Peru
and we had this general graphic test
done of my two oldest kids that are 14
and 10 and and us and I had the 23andme
sequencing done as well and even if I am
ninety-nine point seven percent European
according to the 23andme my kids are
forty-one percent Native American and
and twenty twenty percent Mediterranean
and ten to twelve percent so this Asian
so in that in that battle between me and
my wife on hung on having the genetic
footprint on our kids again I think I
lost a bit but I know this is not very
scientifically this is just more fun to
see how we can use this on origin of our
kids we have worked a lot with education
we have had to EDI road shows in the
Pharaohs we had this in November 2012
and in 2013 we also had bioinformatics
for doctors for researching clinic in
cooperation with epi in Illumina and
this is a very good start on having
people who work in the health sector and
also in the research to get more
knowledge about the usability of
genomics in this way and as you can see
there are a lot of happy people of
gaining this this knowledge this is
something that we will work repeatedly
to to have in this part there has been a
lot of questions when is it suitable to
think more clearly about about genomics
but I think the future is here and as
you can see on the on the nature park
there break glass when ready
your life is in your hand
and I think that part should be now that
we have so much knowledge and it's so
you can use things and we already see
people working with things now so we
should be already thinking about how we
can integrate this into a healthcare in
a positive way one task that I have
missed a bit Alden is attention in the
media because actually I was not
supposed to get so much attention in the
in the media and we didn't really have a
PR plan on that way but we have been a
lot in in the news anyway both locally
but also internationally and that's
that's a part that comes with a project
like this I think and we've been a bit
overwhelmed with with the interest for
the project but we also believe that we
we have a approach that we can work very
good with so how do we see steps in in
this way I I think the first step is a
public health approach where we where we
have some fairly segregated knowledge we
work with this part of the thousand
genomes we do the fair with referenced
you know so we have some local knowledge
and we can use our technology records we
have the genealogy records 200 years
back digitalized we have fairly good
geology records going back for almost
400 years from from our parish registers
and other sources Midwife registers as
well as far as I'm informed we had this
very good system that midwives only got
paid for for delivery that where the kid
was alive so they have then they have
written it very carefully down so they
got paid so we have good references from
their written records but the firm is
referenced you know we can we can
actually make it quite precisely with
using our our digital channel records in
that way so we can have a very good
reference genome for the fairies data
both for research and for the clinical
part
and then we think that we need we need
to approach your specific fairways
disease question in this way to get more
knowledge and see if we can have a
better treatment as well and then we can
begin to work with an integration of the
health care routine whole genome
sequencing in that way from there I
think we can slowly begin to to the well
of our our use of clinical technology
agnostic on our system and and
afterwards we will begin with the
tailored treatment which some people
would call them personalized a way to it
but but this is still more into
individualized in the taalib treatment
part and from there we go to the
precision medicine which I see as where
you not only use the genomic data but
but you have a merging of data sources
to practice this precision medicine in
this way still with a genomic as as the
baseline and from there we can begin to
think about personalized healthcare
because we have enough data that we can
individualize it in the care and in that
way and but to make this work we also
need to empower the sets and to take
responsibility understood that they also
would need to be a part of this
knowledge and to take decision on things
especially in the preventive part of it
so so this in the sixth step will be
both a personalized preventive approach
and a societal prevention approach we
can look at a more societal part of it
and have some tools to work with in
health policy we are we have decided to
have our fortune yearly fortune summit
conference we have this next one we had
one last year in September and then the
next one we have now at the 19th and
20th of September so where we want to
have a presentation of the status of
which we have achieved the last year we
also hope with that we can have a
conference for four isolates we can have
that subject every year as a part of it
and use this
as a connection between researchers
health agencies and companies worldwide
and of course this is a very good
networking for researchers and and bio
and and health business and healthcare
in a way and to have some cutting edge
topics on it so what do we hope as an
outcome in this we have this bio back
access for for health and for research
and for there might be some businesses
that would want to have access to to
this as well to develop some things in
from this knowledge the bio informatics
which is a crucial part in order to make
sense of all this genomic information
maybe to have some targeted expertise
for the global market that could be that
we make some expertise in maybe the
various diseases or some specific
diseases as well as we buy health
services from the outside we could
develop some some niches in the Pharos
to to deliver to to other parts and the
health services are to the ferry system
and could be as well globally and in
this globalized world and we need to
have some software applications
development to have some service for
health staff users some service for for
citizens and to have a sequencing center
which will basically be made for the
Human Genome Project but there is of
course already interest to see was
different kinds of things and as our
main economic sources its fishery and
agriculture those parts of the industry
are very interested in in using these as
well and these are some of the people we
have had been working I should have my
acknowledgement I will not name them all
but say that we have been David
ventilation stops clip of a chicken
Kelly McQueen
and also a few clips in our certificate
otherwise report in that way this has
been a long process of developing of a
lot ideas so there are many people who
were been participating knowing and not
knowing in in our concept
I'll I'd really like to use this cartoon
that as it says men only began to evolve
after he started to cut corners but I
think we are somewhere where this is
getting applicable and usable with the
knowledge of genomics and I will just
end with saying that we you can visit
them fortune to fo slash submit to to
see the conference that we are having so
with that I will thank you for your
attention and for your patience to to
listen from for some of you early for
some of you late and if you have any
question please just send me the
questions
so there are no questions coming in so
but I could tell you if you if you would
like to visit our conference as well you
should look at it's it's not the easiest
play to place to come to to the forums
but it's easy to fly through Copenhagen
so you could come and see this beautiful
landscape and have some knowledge so now
I had a question here statement that it
was very interesting thank you
I think really liked it you got
something out of it and I have a
question on the cost well I guess if you
have been following if you have been
following the genomic the last years you
will always see the cost curve that that
the output is going extremely much off
and the cost is going to string a much
down so that's something we have into
into the our equation but our first
phase of of doing a thousand and with
that set of that cost would be would be
around would be around one point around
to how much would that be in two million
dollars with the first phase
which is not so much I have another
question on the hunter genome sequencing
and that the analysis would be a huge
burden yes there is there is a huge
burden on the analysis but what we are
working with on this part is also
developing areas in order to work with
with these parts and now I have a
question on the future research consent
and know I think I had it in one slide
that you would consent it for being a
part of this biobank
but you need to be to be reconsent it
for research specific research projects
yes are there more questions
I have a question on incidental findings
actually we have when we started this
project the mainstream idea was to give
all information back we we have actually
we have actually worked very much with a
model on not giving information back
telling people that to participate in
this you will be a part of developing
research but that you would have the
right to have you genomic information
included in in future healthcare the
said there is a second question here on
is the government going to take care of
the counseling I will I will combine
these answers our system is it's a
public system so so this counseling is
also a part of this so the counseling
needs to be a part of it and and when
you as a public system do deliver
genetic research genetic results back in
a clinical setting you need to give
counseling back as well that's those are
the rules on the area
so there are still times for some more
questions
okay I would like to thank you very much
for your attention
and if you have any more questions feel
free to send me an email on be ogi at
health dot fo I think you could probably
find my information on on the web page
here as well or you can look at our web
page at www.fortuigence.com